information you're allowed to see is now
coming from the highest office in the
land
my hope is that facebook instead of
taking it personally somehow i'm saying
facebook is killing people that they
would do something about the
misinformation
they owe outrageous information
misinformation about the vaccine you
shouldn't be banned from one platform
and not others if you affor
providing misinformation out there here
now pulitzer prize winning
and independent journalist glenn
greenwald glenn um
the biggest shock here i don't think
it's that the modern left thinks they
can
you know use these social media
companies as their own not true squads
but that the media seems to be just like
whistling past the graveyard
on this your thoughts
well i mean i think the model was when
just weeks before the election
the silicon valley giants united to ban
reporting done by the new york post on
authentic documents about the biden
family
and the media didn't raise any concerns
in fact they supported
it and that sent the signal that the
biden administration once they're in
power could use that model of
suppressing information off of the
internet
with very little objection from the
people who are supposed to defend
free expression and the thing that's so
amazing aura is
even if you're somebody who isn't
incredibly disturbed by the idea that
the government is instructing
social media companies which shouldn't
shouldn't be
allowed to be on the internet these are
the people
least competent to judge what is
misinformation they're the ones who
spent a year saying
that the theory of a covid
lab leak in wuhan was a crazy conspiracy
theory and now they say it's highly
plausible
worse these are the same people who
flooded the country for five years
with deranged conspiracy theories that
putin and the russians had taken control
over the u.s through clandestine sexual
blackmail and now suddenly they want to
act like
we should trust them to determine what
is true and what is false it's
incredibly dangerous
yeah like they haven't been operating a
bureau of disinformation on a on a
multitude of issues as i uh pointed out
in the angle i mean
again when npr glenn writes an article
about ben shapiro's site the daily wire
you know in this thing they quoted jamie
settle director of the
social networks and political psychology
lab at william mary and she said that
they tend
to not provide very much context for the
information they're providing
if you've stripped enough contacts away
any piece of truth
can become a piece of misinformation uh
glenn you can see where this is going
yeah i mean i think you know the the
reality of what's going on
is that these media outlets are losing
their audience
trump was kind of like a four-year sugar
high for them he saved their jobs and
with him gone
their audience is collapsing there's
data today showing that the atlantic the
new york times the guardian huffington
post
have all lost between a third and a half
of their audience in the last year alone
obviously the other two cable networks
combined don't get anywhere near
the audience of this network and so they
look at ben shapiro and other right-wing
voices and they're angry that more
people want to listen to them
than to these corporate media outlets
and so their only option
instead of looking in the mirror and
asking why people don't want to listen
to them
is to try and just silence everybody so
that they maintain their monopoly
over the discourse and everyone is
captive to listen to them because
everyone else has been silenced that's
really all it's about
i i want to get back to a point that i
had made a few minutes ago
how do the democrats let's say it's
mostly happening right now on the
democrat side
how do they think it's actually going to
help them it's like none of these
questions whether it's about
kids and masks or or any of these
questions are they're not going to go
away
right so next year in the midterms the
questions are still going to be out
there and it's better to run themselves
through the paces of
tough interviews tough i mean fair fair
interviews just questions
but instead when you ask a question you
raise a point a data point
then you're a vaccine denier you're you
know you're anti-science you have to be
stopped it's disinformation
i have never seen anything like this
since i lived in the soviet union as a
student in the 1980s glenn
it's it's the same mentality i think it
goes back to the 2016 campaign
when they were not only so sure that
hillary clinton was going to defeat
donald trump but believe they had some
kind of like divine entitlement
for hillary clinton to become president
and when they lost
fair and square they started asking
themselves why did we lose
and instead of looking in the mirror
again they started blaming
everybody except themselves and
especially they started blaming
facebook saying you allowed all this
disinformation you allowed lies about
hillary clinton
and our only option to survive
politically is to control
the means of communication that we no
longer control which is the internet
that was the whole point of the internet
was to liberate us
from not having to be manipulated and
controlled by centralized authority when
they saw
that allowing that freedom jeopardizes
their political interests the only
conclusion that they reach was
we can't allow that anymore we can't
allow this freedom
we need to control it we need to silence
it we need to censor it
and through the trump years it just
escalated and they're like this
authoritarian faction now
that genuinely believes that censorship
is in the public good
yeah it is glenn we're going to keep
tracking it thank you
great to see you tonight hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else